so president putin and foreign minister
lavrov are in the list of sanctioned
people
together with the remaining members the
duma who are supporting
this aggression
and also with rival members of the
sacred russian security council
you know very well that this is an
important step
let me reflect that
only leaders in the world we are
sanctioned by the european union
assad from syria lukashenko from belarus
are now put in from russia
we will also target those in belarus who
collaborate with the russian military
aggression against ukraine
and we will not stop
there
we have also adopted a proposal to
target all i mean all
those who are significantly
uh providing economic support
all who are
having a significant economic
role in supporting the regime following
a television a telephone conversation a
president biden held with
european commission president ursula
vonderlein and in alignment with the
decision by our european allies the
united states will join them in
sanctioning president putin and foreign
minister lavrov and members of the
russian national security team i expect
we'll have more specific details out
later this afternoon on sanctioning
putin and lavrov yesterday president
biden had said that that was on the
table what changed between yesterday and
today well it has been under
consideration and on the table for some
time as you know and
as i just conveyed
the president's
strong view and
strong principle from the beginning of
this conflict and even before i should
say has been to take actions and steps
in alignment with our european partners
and this is certainly evidence of that
just finally on that one what does
sanctioning putin himself do in this the
opinion of this administration a lot of
analysts have said that this is more of
a symbolic move than anything well
without getting into any specific
details i know you're not exactly asking
me this but sort of about financial
assets etc i will leave that to others
to speak to uh certainly the united uh
uh this step that we are doing in
alignment uh and in coordination with
the europeans just sends a clear message
about uh the the strength of the
opposition uh to the actions uh by
president putin and the direction uh in
his leadership of the russian military
yeah i just wanted to ask in the
continuing questions on sanctions yep um
today we saw that the italian government
and the german government both expressed
it said very clearly that they would not
veto
a move to remove russia from the swift
transaction system
can you say a word about how quickly you
think something like that would happen
and whether you believe that that would
be another productive tool and perhaps
another moment you know symbolic uh or
rather an important measure sure well um
again uh the president's principal is
doing taking steps in alignment we are
stronger together especially as we stand
in the face of the uh russian military's
actions and and their invasion of
ukraine as it relates to swift we've
never taken that off the table of course
and i'm certainly not taking it off the
table today so certainly there'll be
ongoing discussions about that as you
know swift is a messaging service that
connects 11 000
banks and
many would argue that there are ways
that
that russia the russian leadership could
get around that over the course of time
but it certainly remains an option on
the table in terms of the timeline i
don't have anything to predict for you
on